they are the people who make your food
pour your drinks and serve you the food
service industry is expected to add more
than 370 thousand jobs by 2031 an
increase of nine percent almost double
the growth of other job sectors but the
industry is struggling to find workers
one program in the Dallas Fort Worth
area is trying to fill that void one
lunch at a time Omar via Franca has more
the lunch rush is about to start triple
check the entire menu every single item
and Chef Joseph Maher is making sure
everything in the kitchen is ready from
the entrees it doesn't caramelize and we
always do it okay to the properly
seasoned side dishes
while out on the floor Connor are you on
better Duty oh my goodness you're a mind
reader Chef Victoria hooker is reminding
servers to greet the hungry customers
with warm bread Byron Bistro isn't your
typical restaurant it's only open once a
week for lunch the menu constantly
changes and everything is sliced seared
and served by students from Byron Nelson
High School's Culinary Academy in Trophy
Club Texas this isn't square pizza or
tacos on Tuesday no it's not what are
you serving uh today on the menu we had
a pretty we have a little beef today we
have heirloin chicken breast we have
Chef's Maher and hooker are teaching the
Next Generation after Decades of working
in kitchens and their own restaurants
the program has steadily grown since
2010 and now has 134 students learning
the ins and outs of the food service
business
freshmen and sophomores learn the basics
by junior year they're crafting decadent
desserts okay so these ones are you in
the freezer that's right on our
chocolate chip here they're learning
math economics and science through
cookies lots of cookies how do you grade
making cookies oh that's a good question
so there's a lot of things to go into it
first we have to make sure they can
scale their food correctly that they can
use the equipment ride they follow the
proper instructions they work clean
organized sanitized that they get the
proper yields
but the heat is on the seniors cook
Grill fry roast and finally plate all
the orders under the watchful eye of
Chef Maher their test comes once a week
when the bistro is open to the public
for lunch if you can get a seat my
favorite part of you know working on the
line being a culinary is you know being
on the line on these busy days cooking
for people seeing everyone lining out
the door eighteen-year-old senior
Brayden Gunter is one of the leaders on
the line he earned a scholarship to an
elite culinary school in Rhode Island
but says he's already learned valuable
life lessons everything that I've
learned from sanitation Health
temperatures to actual methods and how
to cook it's going to be useful my
entire life you know I'd much rather go
buy some groceries and cook myself some
food and you know just rely on doordash
every day Braden and his classmates are
in high demand restaurateurs like Ron
Jankowski owner of the brass tap in
nearby Roanoke have started hiring more
qualified candidates from the program
how important is it to have a new
employee with even just basic no
knowledge of how a kitchen runs it's
extremely helpful like
since I have been so short staffed
my interviewing process has basically
been here's a mirror can you fog it up
you're hired
seventeen-year-old Junior Nyla
Williamson is cooking up long-term plans
I want to go to college at The Culinary
Institute of America get Associates in
baking and pastries and the food
business degree and bachelor's and then
once I have those two I can obviously
like open the bakery she says what
started out as a passion for pastries is
now a vision for her future I want to
have like a little bigger like little
like a mom Paw Thing like it's like a
little town it's like everyone knows
that Bakery that's where you go to get
nyla's amazing cookies and I just don't
know like a little thing that I can call
my own that I built from the ground up
based on the crowds that packed The
Bistro and reviews from the customers
how was it it was amazing the students
from Byron Nelson's Culinary Academy
already have the recipe for success
for CBS Saturday morning Omar
villafranca Trophy Club Texas